JUST BRADFORD CABALLERO
PROTECTING DALLY TODD THE
RHIZOME EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALES
GROVE HERTZBERG WAY SO HER TADO
JONES CAN LONGER LAYERED LLEVA
A GLIDER MELINDA'S MAN. NEWMAN
WE'LL SEND A CHILL OF VOGUE.
HAN FORTUNE TINO ROSS RUBIO
SKINNER STERN AMBERG WHITE
HOUSE SKI WINNER WELL. MEMBERS
A QUORUM IS PRESENT. MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BEYOND
THE REAL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RICE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER TODAY BY SENATOR MAN
AFTER WHICH WE'RE GOING TO ASK
YOU TO REMAIN STANDING AND WILL
BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE BY SENATOR JONES.
SENATOR MACK. IN A WORLD THAT
IS DOUBLING DOWN IN FEAR AND
FEAR MONGERING AND INCREASING
AND INTIMIDATION AND VIOLENCE
AGAINST ASIAN AMERICANS AND
PACIFIC ISLANDERS. EACH OF US
IS CALLED TO RENEWED WITNESS TO
THE DIGNITY OF EACH PERSON.
SAVE US OH GOD FROM THE WAYS IN
WHICH WE ARE COMPLICIT IN
RACISM OF ALL SORTS. FROM
RACISM SO OFTEN CLOAKED IN
PIOUS WORDS. FROM THE
MACHINATIONS OF WHITE SUPREMACY
HIDING IN PROCEDURE. FOR MICRO
AGGRESSIONS THINLY VEILED AN
ARROGANCE AND MACRO AGGRESSIONS
WITH INTENT TO HURT. REGRETS
WHEN THEY DON'T GIVE WAY TO
ACTIONS. DELIVER US OH GOD FROM
JUDGING API PEOPLE BY STANDARDS
BASED IN IGNORANCE AND FEAR.
FROM STAYING SILENT WHEN WORDS
AND ACTIONS OF SOLIDARITY ARE
NEEDED. FROM ALLOWING THOSE OF
NON CHRISTIAN RELIGIONS TO BE
VILIFIED. FROM FAILING TO
NOTICE THAT WE ARE ALL ONE IN
OUR HUMANITY AND OUR DEPENDENCE
ON ONE ANOTHER. GRACIOUS GOD WE
ASK FOR WISDOM AND COURAGE TO
BE LED BY YOUR SPIRIT FOR THE
SAKE OF THE KINGDOM KINGDOM
THAT WE SHARE WITH EACH OTHER.
I'M IN. HIS PLACE YOUR HAND
OVER YOUR HEART WHICH I MEAN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA. AND ALMOST ALWAYS
STANDS. ONE NATION UNDER GOD.
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. I REMEMBER THE
DAY WE HAVE CENTERED WILL MOAN
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATOR. MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DOING
READ. MESSAGE FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WILL BE TEAM READ. REPORTS FROM
COMMITTEES WILL BE ENDING RED
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES
WITHOUT OBJECTION. THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR THE WEEK OF MAY
TENTH TO THIRTEEN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WILL BE APPROVED AS
CORRECTED BY THE MEDICAL.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
ITEMS WERE GOING TO TRY TO GET
THROUGH THE DAY. SPECIAL
CONCERT GOERS. MEMBERS UNDER
MOTIONS ARE REAL RESOLUTIONS WE
HAVE ITEM FIFTY ITEM FIFTY ONE
ITEM FIFTY TWO. ITEM FIFTY
THREE ITEM FIFTY FOUR AND ITEM
FIFTY FIVE B. R. A C. R. FOUR
E. C. R. SIXTY AC ARE SIXTY
FIVE H. C. R. SIX E. SIX A. C.
R. SEVENTY THREE AND I A. C. R.
SEVENTY EIGHT. SO. MEMBERS NOW
WE'RE MOVING TO CONSIDERATION
OF THE DAILY FILE. AGAIN WE
HAVE ABOUT NINETEEN ITEMS WERE
GOING TO TRY TO FALL THROUGH
THE DAY- FIRST WE HAVE A
GOVERNOR GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. WE HAVE ITEMS
FIVE AND SIX SENATOR BAITS ARE
YOU PREPARED. SINNER BETA FOR
SHORT. WELL MA'AM SECRETARY.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
IS THE CONFIRMATION OF RAGTIME
TO THE CALIFORNIA EXPOSITION
AND STATE FAIR BOARD OF
DIRECTORS MR HINE HAS SERVED ON
THIS BOARD SINCE HE WAS FIRST
APPOINTED IN TWO THOUSAND ONE
HE WAS APPROVED BY THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE ON MAY TWELFTH.
ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE. FIVE ZERO
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTE. MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
SENATE APPOINTMENT. FOLLOW HIM
FIVE NINETY NINE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I. ATKINS I
FACE. HI BECKER. FOR JUST HI
BRADFORD I KERR BIO HI CORTESE
FIVE DALLY. GOD HI TORONTO HI
ADNAN FIVE GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE
MY GROWTH. HERTZBERG FIVE WITH
SO HI HER TADO. JONES FIVE CAN
LONGER. LAYERED HI LLEVA I
ACQUIRE I MELINDA'S BY MEN. I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN I A SHOW OF
BOTH. YEAH. PAM HI PORTS AND
TINA HI RALPH. HI RUBIO. HI
SKINNER. HI STERN. AMBERG HI I
LIKE HOW SKI FIVE WINNER I WILL.
HI SENATOR BATES MOVES A CALL
MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING ON A
FILE ITEM SIX SPINNERBAITS.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIX OF THE
CONFIRMATION OF MARY WANT TANA
B. AS DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE PRIOR TO THIS ROLE
SHE WAS SERVING AS THE
DEPARTMENT'S ACTING DIRECTOR.
SHE ALSO SERVED- DMH C. AS
ACTING CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
AND AS DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
HEALTH POLICY AND STAKEHOLDER
RELATIONS SHE WAS APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON MAY
TWELFTH. UNANIMOUSLY FIVE ZERO
VOTE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
APPOINTMENT. HEARING SEE NAINA
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE ITEM SIX. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I BASE I
BECKER I FORGES HI BRADFORD HI
COME BY ADAM HI COURTESY. HI
DALLY. DODD I TORONTO BY ADMIN.
HI GLAZER FIVE DOLLARS HIGH
GROWTH HI HERZBERG I WISH SO.
HI HER TADO HI JONES I CAN
LONGER I LAYERED I. LEIVA. I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S I MEN. I
NEWMAN. I NIELSEN I HAVE A
TELEPHONE HI PAM FIVE FOURTEEN
TINA. HI ROTH FIVE RUBIO FIVE
SKINNER FIVE STERN. AMBERG HI
BY CAL SKI FIVE WINNER HI WELL
I. SENATOR BATES MOVES THE CALL
NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING OUT TO
SENATE THIRD READING. WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF ITEMS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO TRY TO MOVE THROUGH
FIRST UP IS FALL ITEM. FIFTEEN
THE- LABOR ARE YOU PREPARED FOR
FALL ITEM FIFTEEN. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE SENATE
BILL FOUR TEN BY SENATOR LEYVA
AN ACT RELATING TO OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY AND HEALTH- LABOR THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
SP FOUR TEN TO ENSURE THAT
WORKER SAFETY IS NEVER DELAYED
OR SATISFIED AS A RESULT OF
DUPLICATIVE EXPENSIVE AND
UNNECESSARY ANALYSIS. IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN THEN GOVERNOR
JERRY BROWN SIGNED INTO LAW SB
SIX SEVENTEEN WHICH REQUIRE
STATE AGENCIES TO PREPARE AN IN
DEPTH ECONOMIC ASSESSMENT OF
ANY REGULATION WITH AN
ESTIMATED FISCAL IMPACT OF OVER
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS. THIS
ECONOMIC AND ECONOMIC
ASSESSMENT IS CALLED THE
STANDARDIZED REGULATORY IMPACT
ASSESSMENT ALSO KNOWN AS THE
SHARIA. WHEN IT COMES TO WORKER
SAFETY AND HEALTH REFORMS WE'RE
ALREADY AWARE OF THE EXTENSIVE
PROCESS THAT EXISTS BEFORE YOU
RULE CAN BE FINALIZED. THOSE
STEPS INCLUDE THE FOLLOWING.
WHAT A BILL SIGNED INTO LAW IT
OFTEN DIRECTS THE CALIFORNIA
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
STANDARDS BOARD TO TAKE ACTION
ON A PARTICULAR ISSUE. TO
MULTIPLE ADVISORY COMMITTEE
MEETINGS THREE ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURE ACT WHICH FURTHER
ASSESS THE PHYSICAL IMPACT
FISCAL IMPACT. AND FOR THE O.
S. H. S. B. THEN EXTENSIVELY
REVIEWS THE COSTS AND BENEFITS
OF ANY STANDARD. BY THIS POINT
AT LEAST FOR. THOROUGH FISCAL
ANALYSES WILL HAVE BEEN A KURT
HAVE OCCURRED FOR THE RULE
MAKING PROCESS TO BE COMPLETED.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT WHAT THE
SHARIA REVIEW MANDATES A FIFTH
FIFTH FISCAL ANALYSIS IN THE
MIDDLE OF THIS ALREADY VERY
THOROUGH PROCESS. THE TREE CAN
EXTEND THE RULE MAKING PROCESS
BY ONE TO TWO YEARS. OR MORE
AND IN TURN CONTINUE TO
ENDANGER THE LIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS IN THE WORKPLACE
HE FURTHER DELAY IN ADOPTING
SAFETY STANDARDS THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN APPROVED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR. AND
I'VE ALREADY GONE THROUGH
MULTIPLE LEVELS OF
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW. THIS MAY
PLACE WORKERS AT AN INCREASED
RISK OF SERIOUS INJURY OR EVEN
DEATH. PROPOSALS THAT DO NOT
REQUIRE SHARIA SUCH AS THE
INDOOR HEAT STANDARD REQUIRED
BY SB ELEVEN SIXTY SEVEN WHICH
WAS SIGNED INTO LAW IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN. HAVE SUFFERED
SEVERE DELAYS AS A RESULT OF
THIS PROCESS. THE LANGUAGE WHEN
LANGUAGE FOR THE INDOOR HEAT
STANDARD HAS YET TO EVEN BE
PRESENTED TO THE O. S. H. S. B.
DESPITE LEGISLATION REQUIRING
THIS TO HAPPEN OVER TWO YEARS
AGO. THAT IS TWO ADDITIONAL
YEARS THUS FAR THE INDOOR
WORKERS HAVE LABORED AND
GRUELING HEAT WITH NO CLEAR HE
PROTECTIONS UNDER THE LAW. WELL
THE PANDEMIC IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
SOME OF THIS DELAY IN JANUARY
ONE OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
THE DEADLINE WAS ALREADY LONG
GONE WHEN COVERT APPEARED A
YEAR LATER. ALSO IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS TO SIGNIFICANT
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS WERE
APPROVED IN SIX TO SEVEN MONTHS
WHAT PROTECTING WORKERS FROM
WILDFIRE SMOKE AND ANOTHER FROM
COVERT NINETEEN. AS EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS THESE DID NOT
REQUIRE SHARIA BUT THE
REGULATIONS STILL RECEIVED
THROUGH VETTING THOROUGH
VETTING WITH THE PLENTY OF
OPPORTUNITIES FOR AGENCY
ANALYSIS AND STAKEHOLDER
FEEDBACK. THESE AND OTHER
EXPERIENCES HAVE CONFIRMED THAT
SHARIA BRINGS A LITTLE TO THE
WORKER SAFETY RULE MAKING
PROCESS. OTHER THAN GREATER
DELAYS AS SUCH AS BEFORE TEN
EXAMS WORKER SAFETY AND HEALTH
STANDARDS FROM THE REQUIREMENT
THAT ISRAEL MUST BE PERFORMED
WITH SUCH REGULATION IS
PROJECTED TO A FISCAL IMPACT.
OF FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS OR
MORE. ALL OTHER EXIT LAYERS OF
REVIEW INCLUDING INTERNAL
FISCAL ANALYSIS THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE PROCESS THE
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
STANDARDS FOR PUBLIC HEARINGS.
AND MEETINGS AND THE RULEMAKING
STANDARD REMAIN IN PLACE THIS
BILL WRISTLET RESEARCH REFLECTS
THE EXCEPTIONALLY DETAILED
FISCAL. ANALYSIS THAT ALREADY
OCCURS DURING THIS PROCESS AND
ALLOWS THE AFFECTED AGENCIES TO
FOCUS SCARCE RESOURCES. IN MORE
EFFECTIVE WAYS MEMBERS THIS
BILL IS VERY PERSONAL TO ME
WITH MORE WAREHOUSES IN SENATE
DISTRICT TWENTY THAN ANYWHERE
IN THE COUNTRY AND ONLY ONE
OTHER PLACE. IN THE WORLD WE
NEED TO HAVE AN EAGLE INDOOR
HEAT STANDARD WHICH HAS BEEN
PASSED THAT WAS THE ORIGINAL
AUTHOR OF SB ELEVEN SIXTY
SEVEN. NOW WE NEED THAT RULE
MAKING TO BE DONE TO PROTECT
THESE WORKERS MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. ON FALL ITEM FIFTEEN.
CENTERMAN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUES HI- I'VE BEEN TOLD
THAT SINCE THE ORIGINAL
REQUIREMENT OF AN ECONOMIC
IMPACT WAS PASSED BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN THERE HAVE BEEN
ZERO NEW REGULATIONS PASSED OUT
OF THIS S. R. I. A. PROCESS THE
REGULATORY IMPACT ASSESSMENT
AND THAT IS DEEPLY TROUBLING TO
ME THAT SUGGESTS THERE
SOMETHING FLAWED WITH THIS
APPROACH. THAT BEING SAID I
ALSO STRUGGLED AFFECTED I FEEL
LIKE HAVING AN ECONOMIC IMPACT
IN UNDERSTANDING- WE'RE A
REGULATION WILL COME DOWN TO
WHAT ITS EFFECTS WILL BE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE SO- FOR THOSE
REASONS I'M GONNA STAY OFF THIS
BILL HE AND YOU KNOW I DO THINK
THERE'S PROBLEMS WITH THIS BUT
I THINK INFORMATION IS
IMPORTANT FOR US AS WE MAKE NEW
REGULATIONS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
DEBATE ON THIS I DON'T. HEARING
AND SEEING NO ADDITIONAL
MICROPHONES MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
FOLLOWING FIFTEEN. ALAN.
ARCHULETA HI HI AT KINS I BASE
NO BACKER. HI FOR JUST. NO
BRADFORD I COULD BUY A- CORTEZ
E. FIVE DALLY. DODD DURAZO BY
ADMIN HI GLAZER. GONZALEZ HIGH
GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG HI WITH SO.
HER TADO. JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LLEVA FIVE MCGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S. NO MAN. NEWMAN FIVE
NIELSEN NO OCHO ALTHOUGH NO PAN.
I PORTANT TINA. HI RALPH. I
RUBIO. SKINNER HI STERN AMBERG.
WHITE HOUSE SKI. FIVE WINNER I
WOKE NOW. SENATOR LEVEL MOVES
THE CALL NUMBERS REMOVING ON
THE FILE I'M SIXTEEN SENATOR
BAITS ARE YOU PREPARED MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. SENATE
BILL FOUR THIRTY FOUR BY
SENATOR BATES AN ACT RELATING
TO HEALTH AND CARE FACILITIES
SENATOR ROACH. THANK YOU- HOME
MADAM PRESIDENT MR PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS SP FOUR THIRTY FOUR
PROHIBITS AN OPERATOR OF A
LICENSED RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
FACILITY OR A CERTIFIED ALCOHOL
OR OTHER DRUG PROGRAM PROVIDING
ANY FORM OF FALSE ADVERTISING.
OR MARKETING SERVICES MY NAME
THIS BUILD BRANDON'S LAW IN
HONOR OF BRANDON NELSON WHO
TRAGICALLY DIED IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AT THE AGE OF TWENTY
SIX AND I'M LICENSED REHAB
HOME. HIS PARENTS TO SIGN
BRANDON OUT FOR CARE AT THE
HOME WE'RE SURE THAT HE WOULD
RECEIVE THERAPY SESSIONS A CASE
MANAGER THE HOUSE MANAGER AND
MORE UNFORTUNATELY THAT IS NOT
WHAT HE RECEIVED ACCORDING TO A
COMPREHENSIVE INVESTIGATION. BY
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA NEWS
GROUP IT FOUND AND I QUOTE
NELSON DIDN'T HAVE A TEAM OF
PROFESSIONALS OVERSEEING IS
TRANSITION HE APPARENTLY DIDN'T
EVEN GET HIS MEDICATIONS ON
TIME ACCORDING TO HIS PARENTS
AND POLICE REPORTS. WHAT THEY
GOT WERE SALES PITCHES NOT
HEALTH CARE ADVICE THE NELSONS
CONCLUDED END QUOTE I BELIEVE
WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION AS A
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE SURE THAT
NO PERSON HAS TO EXPERIENCE
WHAT BRANDON IS HIS FAMILY WENT
THROUGH. OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS THE LEGISLATURE HAS
RECOGNIZED THAT CONSUMERS WITH
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS HAVE
DISABLING CONDITIONS AND THAT
THESE CONSUMERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES ARE VULNERABLE.
HOWEVER THERE ARE NO PROVISIONS
IN THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE TO CONTROL
UNETHICAL MARKETING PRACTICES
THAT PREY ON DISTRESSED
FAMILIES OR INDIVIDUALS IN
CRISIS WHO ARE SEEKING
TREATMENT. AS A RESULT PATIENTS
AND THEIR FAMILIES CAN BE
MISLED MISDIRECTED AND
MISDIAGNOSED BY AND QUALIFIED
INDIVIDUALS THE GOAL OF THE SP
FOUR THIRTY FOUR USED TO
PROTECT INDIVIDUALS WITH
ADDICTION AND ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE RECEIVING THE TREATMENT
THEY ARE. PROMISED MARKETEERS
WHO KNOW FINALLY AND WE'LL MAKE
MATERI FALSE STATE. WHETHER IT
OUT. OR BY DIRECT COMMUNICATION
WITH CURRENT OR POTENTIAL
PATIENTS MUST BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE S. B. FOR THIRTY
FOUR AUTHORIZES THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES. TO
INVESTIGATE ALLEGATIONS OF
MISCONDUCT AND IMPOSE SANCTIONS
ULTIMATELY THE MEASURE SEEKS TO
PROTECT THOSE WERE AT THEIR
MOST VULNERABLE AND SEEKING
TREATMENT. THE BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM OF ADDICTION
PROGRAMS AND PROFESSIONALS AND
THE ADVOCATES FOR RESPONSIBLE
TREATMENT. A SIMILAR VERSION OF
THIS BILL. PASSES COMMITTEE
UNANIMOUSLY IN TWENTY NINETEEN
BUT WAS VETOED BY THE GOVERNOR
THIS CURRENT BILL ADDRESSES
THOSE CONCERNS AND HAS RECEIVED
NO VOTES NO NO VOTES. THE BILL
PASSED OUT OF SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE AND I RESPECT. WE
ASKED FOR YOUR LIABILITY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BRANDON SLOT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NO MICROPHONES UP
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA HI AT KINS.
HI BETH HI BECKER. I FOR JUST
FIVE BRADFORD I HAVE I GOTTA.
HI CORTESE I DALLY. DOT FIVE
TORONTO. EGGMAN GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HI HERTZBERG
I WAS SO. HI HER TADO HI JONES.
I CAN LONGER. LAYERED HI LLEVA
I REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S I MEAN
IN. I NEWMAN HI NIELSEN BY A
SHOW OF BOTH. HI CAN. I PARTS
AND TINA HI ROTH HI RUBIO. FIVE
SKINNER. I STERN. AMBERG ALL
RIGHT HI BY CAL SKI. I WINNER I
WILL HI. MS OUR THIRD PLEASE
CALL THAT THE MEMBERS. ALAN I.
DALLY HI. TORONTO HI EGGMAN.
CAN LONGER. STERN. AND
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THAT SOME
MEMBERS. EGGMAN I CAN LONGER.
STERN.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL OUT TO MEMBERS. CAN LONGER.
HI STERN. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES NOW
MEMBER WE'RE MOVING ON THE FALL
ITEM TWENTY THREE BY SENATOR
LEAHY OF A- SHE'S AWAY FROM HER
DESK SOONER OR LATER ARE YOU
READY FOR TWENTY THREE MINUTES
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. SENATE
BILL THREE SIXTY THREE BY
SENATOR LEYVA AN ACT RELATING
TO EDUCATIONAL EQUITY. EARLIER
THE FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS SENATE BILL S. B. THREE
SIXTY THREE WILL ENSURE THAT
THE AMERICAN LEGION AND THE
AMERICAN LEGION AUXILIARY
PROVIDES SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR
SIMILAR ACCESS AND
OPPORTUNITIES TO STUDENTS AS
WELL AS NOT DISCRIMINATE BASED
ON GENDER SPECIFICALLY THIS
BILL FURTHERS CALIFORNIA'S GOAL
OF PROVIDING EQUITABLE
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES TO
ALL STUDENTS BY REQUIRING BOTH
GIRLS AND BOYS STATE AND GIRLS
STATE PROGRAMS TO OFFER THE
FOLLOWING. SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR SIMILAR CURRICULUM
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR ACCESS TO
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS AND
FACILITIES TWENTY ONE NUMBER OF
OPPORTUNITIES FOR GIRLS TO
PARTICIPATE AS THERE ARE FOR
BOYS. ANY LIMITATIONS ON THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS NOMINATED
PER SCHOOL SHOP HIGH LEVEL
PROGRAMS AND ALLOW NUMBER
BINARY STUDENTS TO APPLY TO
EITHER PROGRAM. CALIFORNIA HAS
LONG HELD THAT ACCESS TO
EDUCATION IS A FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT FOR ALL PEOPLE REGARDLESS
OF THEIR GENDER. SADLY YOUNG
WOMEN PARTICIPATING IN
CALIFORNIA GIRL STAY ARE NOT
AFFORDED COMPATIBLE CIVICS
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES AS
YOUNG MEN IN CALIFORNIA BOYS
STATE. EVERY YEAR WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF THE PANDEMIC
APPROXIMATELY ONE THOUSAND
YOUNG MEN PARTICIPATE IN BOYS
STATE. VISIT SACRAMENTO AND THE
STATE CAPITAL DURING THE SUMMER
ON THE OTHER HAND CALIFORNIA
GIRLS STATE. WITH A NINETEEN
EIGHTIES ERA CAP OF FIVE
HUNDRED AND FORTY PARTICIPANTS
ARE ABLE TO PARTAKE IN SOME
ASPECTS OF CIVIC EDUCATION BUT
ARE NOT AFFORDED THE SAME
ACCESS AND OPPORTUNITY TO THE
GOVERNMENT AS BOYS HEALTH.
ASSEMBLY AND COMING TO
SACRAMENTO AND VISITING THE
CAPITOL ONE CANNOT DENY THAT
THE PROGRAM'S PRESENCE IN
SACRAMENTO AFFORDS
OPPORTUNITIES THAT STUDENTS MAY
NOT OTHERWISE HAVE. OTHER
INEQUITIES ALSO EXIST SUCH AS
APPLICATION FEES REGISTRATION
FEES CAREER FAIRS AND THE
LEARNING OF OUTDATED SONGS THE
FOCUS MORE ON THE PARENTS OF
YOUNG WOMEN THEN THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES IN LIFE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT YOUNG WOMEN ARE
OFFERED THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES
AND SAME TYPE OF EXPOSURE TO
GOVERNMENT AS YOUNG MEN. IN THE
WORDS OF SALLY RIDE THE FIRST
WOMAN IN SPACE YOU CANNOT BE
WHAT YOU CANNOT SEE SO IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT YOUNG
WOMEN ARE NOT DISADVANTAGED AND
ARE ALSO ABLE TO VISIT THE
HALLS OF POWER IN SACRAMENTO.
AND THE CAPITAL IF YOUNG MEN
PARTICIPATING BOYS STATE DO SO
AS WELL. I WANTED TO NOTE THAT
THE AMERICAN LEGION HAS REMOVED
THEIR OPPOSITION THE AMERICAN
LEGION AUXILIARY REMAINS
OPPOSED DUE TO THE INFORMATION
DATE WHICH WE ARE COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THEM ON. MEMBERS
ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. THANK YOU ANY FOR THE
DISK OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. IN
NINETEEN NINE MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FOLLOWING
TWENTY THREE. ALAN I ARCHULETA
HI AT KINS I BASE. BACKER FIVE
FOUR JUST. BRADFORD HI CABRERA
HI CORTEZ E. I. DALLY. GOD HI
TORONTO HI ADNAN I GLAZER HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI TIDO
HI JONES. CAN LONGER. LAYERED I
LLEVA I REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S.
MAN HI NEWMAN I NIELSEN. BUT
SHOW VOGUE NO PAM FIVE FORTUNE
TINO I BROUGHT. HI RUBIO. I
SKINNER. FIVE STERN. AMBERG HI
HI WE CASKEY I WINNER HI WELK.
SENATOR PLEASE CALL OUT TO
MEMBERS. BASED GORGEOUS. DALLY.
JONES CAM AUGER. MELINDA'S
NIELSEN. STERN WELK. M.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THAT SOME
MEMBERS. FAITH PORGES DALLY
JONES CAMCORDER I MELINDA'S.
NIELSEN STERN. WELK. BY TWENTY
NINE KNOWS TOO THE MEASURE
PASSES NO MEMBERS WERE MOVING
ON THE FOLLOWING TWENTY FOUR
SENATOR DAUGHTER YOU PREPARE TO
PRESENT THAT I DON'T I SEE THE
IDEAS MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE.
READ SENATE BILL THIRTEEN BY
SENATOR DODD AN ACT RELATING TO
LOCAL AGENCY FORMATION AND
OCCURRING THE URGENCY THERE OF
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY FOR
HER DAUGHTER. THIS PRESENT
MEMBERS AS P. THIRTEEN WILL
EXTEND THE SUNSET OF A PILOT
PROGRAM IN NAPA AND SAN BERNIE
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTIES WHICH
RESPONDS TO THE COUNTY'S NEEDS
TO ACCOMMODATE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OPTIONS AMONG OTHER
THINGS. OTHERS NO OPPOSITION
THE BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS I DON'T.
NINETY NINE IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION TO USING AN UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THIS I DON'T. I
BECAUSE YOU YOU HAVE. NO NOT ON
THE SIDE OF OKAY. FIRSTWE HAVE
URGENCY SO WILL FIRST CALL THE
ROLL ON THE URGENCY. WELL IT'S
UNANIMOUS SO UNANIMOUS ON THE
URGENCY. THIRTY EIGHT ZERO IN
UNANIMOUS ON THE- MOTION THIRTY
EIGHT ZERO MOTION PASSES. NOW
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO
FOLLOW I DON'T KNOW TWENTY FIVE
BY SENATOR WHY BECAUSE HE HE IS
READY MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL I MEAN PLEASE
READ I'M SORRY. SENATE BILL
FOUR SIXTY SIX BY SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE SKI AN ACT RELATING TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. CENTER WHAT
COSBY. US PRESIDENT MEMBERS
THIS IS A DISTRICT BILL WOULD
ALLOW THE CITY OF SANTA CLARA
TO EITHER SELL OR LEASE
PROPERTY LOCATED AT FIVE
HUNDRED PATTON STREET. IN ORDER
TO CREATE AN ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY BUT LET'S SAY PARTY
SHALL FIRST APPROVED THE SALE
OR LEASE BY RESOLUTION AFTER
PUBLIC HEARING AND IT'S A
DEVELOPMENTAL IMPROVE OUR
COMMUNITY AND PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED HOUSING ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND I URGE. AND I
BOTH. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HERE IN NC NINE MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE I'M TWENTY FIVE. ALAN
FIVE ARCHULETA HI AT KES FIVE
BABIES. BECKER HI FOR JUST.
BRADFORD HI CABRERA FIVE
COURTESY HI DALLY. NO GOD. FIVE
TORONTO HI ADNAN HI GLAZER HI
CONSOLIDATES I GROWTH. FIVE
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER. I
LAYERED I LLEVA I MCGUIRE.
MELINDA'S MAN. HI NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. I A TRIO OF BOTH. I
PAN I FORTUNE TINO. I. ROSS I
RUBIO HI SKINNER I STERN.
AMBERG I Y. CASKEY FIVE WINNER
HI WELL I. RICHARD PLEASE CALL
OUT TO MEMBERS. BABIES I FOR
JUST. MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S.
STERN. FIVE THIRTY FIVE KNOWS
ONE THE MEASURE PASSES NO
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON THE
FOLLOWING TWENTY SIX SENATOR
BECKER YOU PREPARED HE IS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SEVEN EIGHTY SIX BY
SENATOR BACKER AND AFTER
LEADING TO THE SANTA CLARA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT CENTER
BOOKER THE FLOOR'S YOURS. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS. J. PRESENT
SP SEVEN EIGHTY SIX A
DISABILITY CAN SAVE WATER
RATEPAYERS SANTA CLARA COUNTY
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. ONE
PROVISIONS IN THE DISTRICT'S
ACT HAVE HELPED PEOPLE WITH
SEVEN DECADES OF GROWTH.
RESULTING UNNECESSARY COSTS FOR
VALLEY WATER AND THE REPAIRS.
SEVENTY SIX UPDATE ANTIQUATED
LIMITS ON BOND ISSUANCE THE
FOUR STAR WATER FINANCE FOR THE
LARGEST WATER SUPPLY AND FLOOD
PROTECTION PROJECTS IN THE
STATE USING COSTLY CONTRACTUAL
BORROWING. THE BOND FORMS THIS
BILL WILL GIVE VALUE ARE THE
SAME ON A THIRTY THE OTHER
REGIONAL WATER AGENCIES LIKE
THE METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT
ALREADY HAVE. SEVENTY SIX TO
SEE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND IS
NO OPPOSITION COLLEAGUES ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. MEMBERS ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON FILE
ITEM TWENTY SIX. JUNE THIRTY
NINE MIN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
AT KENS FIVE BABIES. BACKER HI
FIVE PORCHES I BRADFORD HI
KAVEH ADAM HI CORTESE I DALLY.
I DON. HI TORONTO BY ADMIN HI
GLAZER HI CONDOLENCE ARI GROWTH.
I HEARD SPURRED I WAS SO. HI
FURTADO I JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S I MEN. I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I WOULD SHOW BOTH. I
PAN. HI PERSON TINA I. ROSS. HI
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN. NUMBER
FIVE WHAT KIND OF SKI I WINNER
I WELL I. HOME SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL UP TO MEMBER. FAITH STERN.
FOR MORE TIME ON THE APPS TO
MEMBER. FAITH. FAITH I STERN.
MEMBERS THAT'S THIRTY EIGHT ALL
EYES ZERO KNOWLES THE MEASURE
PASSES SNOW REMOVING A FALL
ITEM THIRTY. THANKS SENATOR ON
BERG ARE YOU PREPARED HE IS.
SENATE BILL FORTY THREE BY
SENATOR UMBERG AN ACT RELATING
TO VETERANS CENTER REMEMBER.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS-
THIS BILL SIMPLY CLARIFIES THAT
SHOULD CEMETERY VETERANS
CEMETERY BUILDING- INE WILL BE
THE CITY OF IRVINE THAT MAKES
THE DETERMINATION AS TO ITS
LOCATION- GINGIVAL. HEY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING C. NINE MEMBERS
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USE IN A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. THE SUPPORT YOU KNOW
YOU HAVE OBJECTION. NOW OKAY.
SOON HEARING NO OBJECTION. ARE
YOU STURDY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM THIRTY
FIVE THAT SENATOR PORN TINO HE
IS. READY MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE. SENATE BILL TO
TWENTY EIGHT BY SENATOR PART
INTO. AND ACTUALLY TO LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL. AND YOU. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I RISE
TO PRESENT SP THREE TWENTY
EIGHT WHICH IS A CLEAN UP TO SP
THREE TWENTY EIGHT MY LANDMARK
SCHOOL LATE START BILL FROM.
LAST SESSION- THIS BILL FOLLOW
THROUGH ON SEVERAL COMMITMENTS
THAT I MADE DURING THE LAST
SESSION TO EXEMPT OUT CERTAIN
RURAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS- TO
ADJUST FUNDING FOR. AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS SO THEY CAN BE
USED FOR BEFORE FORCE GROUP
SCHOOL PROGRAMS I WANT TO
COMPLIMENT THE CHAIR THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE FOR WORKING
WITH MY STAFF. AND MY SENATE
COLLEAGUES. FROM BALDWIN PARK
ON SUGGESTING THE AFTER SCHOOL
FLEXIBILITY I THINK IT MAKES
THE SITUATION MUCH STRONGER-
AND WE HAVE DEFINED ROLES
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND WE ALSO
HAVE MADE SOME OTHER
EXEMPTIONS. IN WHAT I THINK IS
STORK APPROACH TO HELP KIDS AS
WE GO BACK TO SCHOOL START
LATER IN THE MORNING SO THEY
HAVE BETTER MENTAL HEALTH THINK
ABOUT SUICIDE LESS THAN
ACTUALLY DO STRONGER
ACADEMICALLY BASED ON HAVING
MORE SLEEP AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU ANY
DESCRIPTION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM
SOONER RUBIO. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT OF COURSE I LIKE TO
THINK MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOCKING
OUT A- FOR THIS MEASURE AND FOR
HIS THOUGHTFULNESS- I JUST WANT
TO RECOGNIZE EFFORTS TO
BRINGING ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
TOGETHER SO MUCH SO THAT HE
ACTUALLY WENT TO MY DISTRICT
AND WE HAD DISCUSSIONS WITH
ALL. SUPERINTENDENTS AND
TEACHERS AND REALLY THEY STATED
THEIR CONCERNS AND- THE AUTHOR
WAS SO GRACIOUS TO REALLY
LISTEN TO THEIR CONCERNS AND
THIS- CLEAN UP BILL RE RE FLAX
WHAT THEY WANTED TO SEE HIM
WITH THAT I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU IN ADDITION IS CHRISTIAN
AND A VERY. ZERO NINE CENTER
POINT OR JULY TO CLOSE THIS
ASKED I BOUGHT. SPENCER THIRD
PLEASE GO THE ROLL FILE ITEM.
THIRTY ALAN. I ARCHULETA I CAN.
BABIES BECKER FIVE FORTUS.
BRADFORD I HAVE A HI CORTEZ HE
FIVE DALLY. DODD FIVE THERE ARE
SO HI ADNAN. HI GLAZER. HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I WISH SO FIVE HER
TADO. HI JONES. CAN LONGER. I
LAYERED HI LLEVA. I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S. MAN FIVE NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN. A SHOW OF BOTH. NO PAN%
FIVE PERSON TINA I. ROSS. I
RUBIO. HI SKINNER HI STERN
AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI. FIVE
WINNER I WILL HI. HOME
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. AT KINS. FAITH
FOR JUST. DALLY GROVE I. JONES
MELINDA'S. NIELSEN. NO STERN.
MOVE THE CALL. FIVE THIRTY NOSE
TO THE MEASURE PASSES NOW
MOVEMENT MOVING ON THE FILE
ITEM THIRTY EIGHT SENATOR
ATHOUGH SHE'S PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. SENATE
BILL SEVEN HUNDRED BY SENATOR
DOOR ALSO AND ACTUALLY INTO
EMPLOYMENT SENATOR ALSO THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS SB
SEVEN HUNDRED IS A SIMPLE BILL
THAT DIRECTS ET DE TO GIVE A
MISCLASSIFIED POOR DRIVERS THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BENEFITS
THEY LEGALLY DESERVE. THIS BILL
HOLDS COMPANIES RESPONSIBLE IF
THEY TRY TO DEPRIVE THEIR
WORKERS OUT OF UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE AND THE STATE OUT OF
TAXES DURING THE PANDEMIC IT
BECAME VERY CLEAR THAT YOU I.
BENEFITS OUR LIFELINE FOR MOST
WORKERS. YEAH IT IS COVERED YET
AND THE AMOUNT OF CARGO IN THE
PORTS DROPPED MANY PORT TRUCK
DRIVERS FOUND THEMSELVES OUT OF
WORK WHEN THEY APPLIED FOR
BENEFITS THEY WERE INITIALLY
DENIED. EVEN WORSE SOME
MISCLASSIFIED DRIVERS WERE
DEEMED TO BE EMPLOYERS OF OTHER
DRIVERS MAKING THEM LIABLE FOR
UNEMPLOYED ON- MAKING THEM
LIABLE FOR UNPAID YOU I. TAXES
INSTEAD OF THE COMPANIES ARE
PROFITING FROM THEIR HARD WORK
BUT THE INITIAL LEVEL ADD
DENIED BENEFITS FORCE THE
CLAIMANTS TO FILE APPEALS WHICH
THEY WON. BUT AFTER A LENGTHY
PROCESS AS WE SEVEN HUNDRED
SIMPLY DIRECTS ET DE TO COMPLY
WITH TWO KEY DECISIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE APPEALS BOARD THAT
RIGHTFULLY FOUND DRIVERS TO BE
THE EMPLOYEES AND THE TRUCKING
COMPANY. NOT A FELLOW WORKER TO
BE THE EMPLOYER WHO HAD TO PAY
HAS TO PAY THE U. I. TAXES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU ANY FOR
DISCUSS OR DEBATE THE SIDE
SENATOR. YOU MR PRESIDENT I
RESPECTFULLY UP TO THE BILL YOU
KNOW THE IS BENEFITING THE ASK
I'M OVER THE CO THAT YOU THAT
WE HAVE IN TWENTY. AND THERE IS
ESTIMATES OF REPORTED A
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF FRAUD. IN
THE PRISON SYSTEM ALONE THEY'RE
ESTIMATING TWO BILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF FRAUD AND THEN THEY'RE
ALSO ESTIMATING- TEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN OF BENEFITS AND
PAYMENTS THAT WERE PAID OUT TO
INDIVIDUALS THAT THEY HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO CONFIRM THEIR
IDENTITY. THE UNEMPLOYMENT YOU
I TRUST IS 1100% EMPLOYER
FUNDED AND I UNDERSTAND THE
AUTHORS- WILLINGNESS AND HER
DESIRE TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
THAT ARE RE. ENTITLE TO EDT
BENEFITS WOULD GET THOSE EDG
BENEFITS BUT I THINK THIS BILL
GOES DOWN A VERY SLIPPERY SLOPE
AND THE REASON WHY IS. IF YOU
ARE A CONTRACTOR IN YOU-
CONTRACT WITH ANOTHER COMPANY
OR ANOTHER ORGANIZATION A TRUCK
DRIVING ORGANIZATION OR A TRUCK
DRIVER AND THAT PERSON OR THAT
ENTITY HIRES FIVE OTHER DRIVERS
YOU ARE NOT AN EMPLOYEE OF THE
ORIGINAL CONTRACTOR YOU ARE AN
EMPLOYEE OF THE TRUCK DRIVER.
WHO SECURED THOSE SERVICES. SO
TIM THE ARRAY CON REECE. FOR
ALL OF THOSE EDT PAYMENTS WHEN-
IN THIS SITUATION WOULD. MAKE
MAJOR CONTRACTORS OR
CONTRACTORS THAT SUPPLY TO
SUBCONTRACTORS- IT WOULD SET
PRECEDENCE FOR THEM SO THINK
ABOUT THAT CALIFORNIA BUILDINGS
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES. IF YOU
HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL WHO'S
BUILDING A- A LARGE SHOPPING
CENTER AND THEY HIRE FIFTY
SIXTY SUBCONTRACTORS THAT DO
FRAMING ELECTRICAL OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT. THIS BILL WOULD SET
PRECEDENCE THAT THE MEAT THE
PRIME CONTRACTOR WOULD BE
SUBJECT TO ALL OF THE EDT
PAYMENTS- AND ON THERE. EDT
ROLES WHEN THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
THOSE EMPLOYEES RECORDS. LIKE I
SAID I UNDERSTAND WHERE THE
AUTHOR IS GOING TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THAT INDIVIDUALS GET.
THESE BENEFITS THAT DESERVE
THESE BENEFITS BUT TO HAVE
SOMEBODY RESPONSIBLE FOR THOSE
BENEFITS THAT HAD NO CUSTODY
CARE CONTROL OVER HIRING THOSE
AND EMPLOYEES. THAT BELONG TO
ANOTHER COMPANY OR ANOTHER
PERSON. IS JUST NOT THE RIGHT
SOLUTION WE HAVE A HUGE PROBLEM
THERE'S ESTIMATED THIRTY
BILLION DOLLARS IN UNEMPLOYMENT
AND YOU I TRUST FUND OVER DRAFT
WHICH IS GOING TO FALL ON THE
BACKS OF EMPLOYERS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. OVER THE NEXT
YEAR SO THINK ABOUT THAT AS
WELL- A LOT OF IT BEING
FRAUDULENT PAYMENTS THAT WERE
PAID OUT. BUSINESSES ARE GOING
TO BE ON THE HOOK FOR PAYING
THAT BECAUSE THE U. I TRUST
FUND IS 1100% EMPLOYER FUNDED.
AND SO I AGAIN I AGREE WITH YOU
WHAT THE AUTHOR IS TRYING TO DO
TO MAKE SURE THOSE THAT DESERVE
BENEFITS. AND GET THOSE
BENEFITS BUT I THINK WE'RE
GOING AFTER THE WRONG
INDIVIDUAL TO PROVIDE THOSE
BENEFITS AND. I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER- DEBATE.
ON THIS. NINETY NINE SENATOR
ALSO WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU- I JUST WONDER
RESPECTFULLY. EXPLAIN AND
DISAGREE THAT THIS IS NOT ABOUT
SUBCONTRACTED OUT SITUATIONS
THIS IS ABOUT MISS CLASSIFYING
PORT TRUCK DRIVERS AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ASKING TO
CLARIFY IS TO ALLOW THEM WHO
HAVE BEEN MISCLASSIFIED- NOT TO
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE LENGTHY
DELAY OF AN APPEALS COURT WHICH
THEY HAVE DONE OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN AND HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF CASES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM THIRTY EIGHT. ALAN
I ARCHULETA HI AT KINS. EIGHT
NO BACKER HI FOR JUST NO
BRADFORD I HAVE A HI COURTESY
HI DALLY NO DODD. HI TORONTO HI
EGGMAN I BELIEVE- HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO. HI JONES. NO CAMERA UNDER.
I LAYERED I LLEVA I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S NO MAN HI NEWMAN I
NELSON NO A SHOW OF BOTH. NO
PAN HI FORTUNE TINO HI ROTH HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER. FIVE STERN
NUMBER HI I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER I WILL. NO. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL UPS MEMBERS. ATKINS
STERN. MARCH TWENTY EIGHT WHO
KNOWS NINE THE MEASURE PASSES
NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING TO FALL
ITEM FORTY TWO. SENATOR PAN ARE
YOU PREPARED FOR FOLLOWING HIM
FORTY TWO HE IS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FORTY TWO BY SENATOR
PAN RELATIVE TO A A. P. I. DAY
AGAINST BULLYING AND HATE THANK
YOU SENATOR BAM. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT SENATORS AS CHAIR OF
THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I AM PROUD
TO PRESENT ITS YOUR FORTY TWO
WHICH RECOGNIZES MAY EIGHTEENTH
TOMORROW. AS A API DAY AGAINST
PULLING AND HATE. BY MAY
EIGHTEENTH OR MAY EIGHTEENTH IS
VINCENT CHAN'S BIRTHDAY WHO
WOULD HAVE TURNED SIXTY SIX
THIS YEAR IF HE'S STILL ALIVE.
HOWEVER IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO
THE TENSION WAS MURDERED AT AGE
TWENTY SEVEN. WHEN TWO
CAUCASIAN MALES BEAT HIM TO
DEATH. EIGHT DAYS BEFORE THE
WEDDING. THE TWO MEN THAT
KILLED TEN WERE CHRYSLER AUTO
WORKERS. AND THOUGHT HE WAS
JAPANESE THEY BLAME TENSION FOR
THE SUCCESS OF THE JAPANESE
AUTO INDUSTRY. ALTHOUGH THE
STATE OF MICHIGAN WHERE THIS
OCCURRED HAD ALMOST FOURTEEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE INCARCERATED
INCARCERATED IN THEIR STATES
AND A DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER
OF THEM WERE PEOPLE OF COLOR.
BOTH WHITE MURDERS SERVED NO
JAIL TIME FOR THEIR HATE CRIME.
THIS MISCARRIAGE OF JUSTICE
FUEL THE NATIONAL ASIAN
AMERICAN ACTIVIST MOVEMENT THAT
CONTINUES TO THIS DAY. ACTOR
CHANGES ONE OF THE NATIONAL NOT
NONPROFITS CONTINUING TO
MOVEMENT WITH THE MISSION TO
FIGHT AGAINST HATE AND BULLYING
DIRECTED AT THE ASIAN AMERICAN
AND NATIVE HAWAIIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER COMMUNITY. THEIR
VISION IS TO HAVE A WORLD WHERE
ALL USE INCLUDING. THE API
COMMUNITY TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GROW UP FEELING
PROUD AND SUPPORTED IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THEIR IDENTITIES
AND SHARING OF THEIR STORIES.
HOW DOES THE ASIAN AMERICAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITY
FACES ANOTHER RISE OF HATE
INCLUDING MURDERS. THIS MESSAGE
IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER.
PLEASE JOIN ME AND THE ASIAN
ATI LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS AND
TAKING A STAND AGAINST HATE AND
BULLYING. I SPECIALLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE FOR S. E. R. FORTY
TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SENATOR MAN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO THANK MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM SACRAMENTO FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AS WE ALL
KNOW ASIAN AMERICANS ARE FACING-
AT LEAST IN OUR LIFETIMES AND
UNPRECEDENTED LEVEL OF HATE OF
ALL KINDS. AND I THINK THE
STATISTICS REALLY DON'T
CAPTURE. THE UBIQUITY WITH
WHICH ANTI ASIAN A HATE IS
OCCURRING- BECAUSE FOR EVERY
CRIME THAT SUBMITTED FOR
COMMITTED FOR EVERY ACTUAL
ATTACK. THEIR COUNTLESS
INCIDENTS WHERE ASIAN AMERICANS
ARE BULLIED THEY'RE INTIMIDATED
THEIR SPAT UPON- THEY'RE CALLED
RACIST INSULTS NONE OF THAT IS
REPORTED TO POLICE. I THINK ALL
OF US IN THIS ROOM HAVE BEEN
SUBJECT TO BOWLING OR TAKEN
PART IN BOWLING. OR MORE
COMMONLY HAVE HAVE EXPERIENCE
AND WITNESS BOWLING. AND WE ALL
KNOW THAT BULLYING AT ITS
HEART. ONLY SUCCEEDS WHEN
BYSTANDERS STAY SILENT. AND I
THINK THAT THE MESSAGE FOR
TOMORROW FOR ALL OF US. HAS TO
BE NOT JUST ABOUT PASSING
RESOLUTIONS. BUT BUT GETTING
OUT THERE AND CONDEMNING. ANTI
ASIAN HATE ANTI ASIAN BOWLING
THERE CAN BE NO QUARTER FOR
THIS RIGHT NOW. PEOPLE FEEL
LIKE THEY CAN GO OUT THERE AND
SOCIALLY- IN PUBLIC COMMIT.
ACTS OF RACISM SOMETIMES VERY
VIOLENT. AND THEY BELIEVE THAT
THAT IS THE MAJORITARIAN
SENTIMENT AND WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT NOBODY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA FEELS THAT THAT
IS ACCEPTABLE. THIS I AN
ACCEPTABLE SENTIMENT THE VOICE
IN PUBLIC AND THAT CAN ONLY
HAPPEN IF WE THE BYSTANDERS ARE
LOUD IN OUR CONDEMNATION OF
THIS SO. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SENATOR GONZALES. THE
PRESIDENT- I TOO WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUES- BOTH FROM.
IRVINE AND MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD- I THINK THAT IT IS
INCUMBENT UPON US EVEN NOT
BEING FROM ASIAN DESCENT TO BE
ABLE TO SPEAK UP IN SOLIDARITY
WITH OUR- API- COLLEAGUES THAT
ARE EPA COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
HAVING ONE OF THE LARGEST API
COMMUNITIES IN LONG BEACH THE
CAMBODIAN COMMUNITY WHO HAS
GIVEN SO MUCH BEING REFUGEES.
THEIR ACCOMPLISHMENTS IN TERMS
OF SMALL BUSINESS THOSE SHOULD
BE LIFTED U WHILE ALSO
DENOUNCING THE HATE THAT IS
CURRENTLY GOING ON SO WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I. VOTE
AS WELL. THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO. PRESIDENT THANK YOU I
ALSO STAND IN SUPPORT OF S. C.
R. FORTY TWO AND I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO AND IRVINE FOR ALSO
BRINGING THIS FORWARD- WE ARE
JUST LIVING THROUGH SOME TRYING
TIMES AND- WE- ALL NEED TO
STAND TOGETHER. GATHER IN
SOLIDARITY AND SHORT. AND SAY
WE WILL NOT STAND FOR ANY OF
THIS HATE. AND TO AN ASSAULT ON
SOME WONDERFUL PEOPLE I HAVE A
LARGE API COMMUNITY MEANT. THAT
I TRULY APPRECIATE AND HAVE
GROWN TO. LOVE AND RESPECT AND
I JUST WANT US TO CONTINUE TO
BE LOUD ABOUT THIS ISSUE AND
CONTINUE TO SAY WE WILL NOT
STAND FOR IT AND WITH THAT I
ALSO. PUT MY SUPPORT AND ASK
FOR MICHAEL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU IN ADDITION DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SENATOR NELSON.
PRESIDENT AND THE SENATE IS A
ONE OF THE- OF THE ASIAN TO
ISLANDER PUBLIC. IS I WATCHED
OVER THE TWO YEARS OF THIS
ORGANIZATION GROWING AND
EXPANDING EVEN NATIONWIDE. BUT
I SIMULTANEOUSLY WATCH
PARTICULARLY IN MORE RECENT
YEARS AN ACCELERATION. OF
ASSAULTIVE BEHAVIOR TOWARDS
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICANS. PROTECTED IN THE
LAST TWO THREE YEARS I REALLY
DON'T UNDERSTAND IT BUT THIS IS
THE WAY AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO TAKE A STAND AND SAY NO THIS
IS NOT OKAY. IN AMERICA. THIS
PARTICULAR ETHNIC GROUP WHICH
SUFFERED THEIR OWN TRAGEDIES
OVER THE YEARS- THE
INTERMITTENTLY WORLD WAR TWO.
AND THEN THE TRYING TO COME
BACK AS THEY ALL SUCCESSFULLY
HAVE DONE. BUT THIS IS A GOOD
STATEMENT FOR US TO MAKE I URGE
AND I WILL. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR THE
VERY CENTER OF AFTER. I THANK
MY COLLEAGUES SPENT SATURDAY
AND THEY HAVE MANY SATURDAYS
OVER THE LAST FEW MONTHS MIGHT
DISAGREE BATTLEGROUND AGAINST
API. CAN YOU HEAR ME. YOUR
GONNA YEAH LIKE MANY RIGHT
RIGHT YEAH MMHM YEAH WE CAN
HEAR YOU RECORD. TO NOT FIVE.
LIKE MANY. THIS RALLY WAS
ORGANIZED BY YOUNG IN MY
DISTRICT BEEN TO ONES IN MOUNT
VIEW INSTRUMENTE IN MILLBRAE
PALO ALTO AND I THINK THIS
RESOLUTION SAN A STRONG MESSAGE.
AND A DAY TO READ AROUND FOR
THE COMMUNITY WILL BE IMPORTANT
AND I KNOW MANY PEOPLE MY
DISTRICT WILL LOOK FORWARD TO
THIS AND RESERVING THIS AND
EXPECT TO ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING THE SCENE NO
ADDITIONAL MICROPHONE SENATOR
PAN WHICH YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
BUT AFTER WE GOT. THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH I DO WANNA THANK- MY
GOOD FRIENDS FROM A LONG BEACH
AND BALDWIN PARK TO HIM- AND
MENLO PARK FOR STANDING IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE API
COMEDIAN ALL OF YOU WHO WILL BE
CASTING AND I VOTE ON THIS
RESOLUTION I STRICTLY OSCAR
NIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THIS MEASURE.
HEARING CENA HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
MEMBERS WERE MOVING O TO FALL
ITEM FORTY THREE CENTER ADMIN
SHE'S PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE RESOLUTION
THIRTY ONE BY SENATOR ADMIN
RELATIVE TO HARVEY MILK DAY.
SENATOR GRAHAM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TODAY I RISE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS TO PRESENT S. R. THIRTY
ONE HONORING A HERO AND PIONEER
IN THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY HARVEY
MILK WHO WAS THE FIRST OPENLY
GAY ELECTED OFFICIAL IN ANY
MAJOR U. S. CITY AND CARRIES A
LEGACY OF BEING AN ICON. WITHIN
THAT MODERN LGBTQ CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT. MR MILLER RAN
SUCCESSFULLY IN SEVERAL
ELECTIONS BUT HIS PERSEVERANCE
FINALLY PAID OFF WHEN HE WAS
ELECTED TO THE SAN FRANCISCO
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. IS
UNPRECEDENTED ELECTION
CONTINUES TO INSPIRE US TODAY
TO INCREASE OUR REPRESENTATION
EVERYWHERE. LOOKING TO FIGHT L.
G. B. T. Q. DISCRIMINATION MILK
WAS A SOURCE OF REPRESENTATION
AND A TIME WHEN MANY WERE TOO
AFRAID TO BE THEMSELVES. HE
ACTIVELY ENCOURAGED THE
COMMUNITY TO EXPRESS OUR
IDENTITIES AND LIVE THEIR
TRUTH. IS LIKE A TRAGICALLY CUT
SHORT AFTER BEING ASSASSINATED
BY HIS FORMER COLLEAGUE DAN
WHITE INSURING TRIAL TRIAL WAS
AN INJUSTICE TO MIKE'S LIFE AND
REMINDS US OF THE ONGOING
FIGHT. FOR FAIRNESS IN OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM. FOR THE NEW
GENERATION TODAY WE CAN
REMEMBER HIS WORDS WHICH TOLD
US NOT TO SIT QUIETLY IN THE
FACE OF INEQUALITY WHICH
INSTRUCTED US TO WORK TOGETHER
IN A BATTLE AGAINST ALL FORMS
OF OPPRESSION. IN A WORLD WHERE
WE HAVE YET TO ENSURE EQUALITY
FOR ALL HARVEY MILK'S IMPACT AS
A TRAILBLAZER AND CIVIL RIGHTS
ADVOCATE MOVES US TO CONTINUE
FIGHTING TO CARRY ON THE
LEGACY. OF NOT JUST HARVEY MILK
BUT ALL THOSE WHO HAVE GIVEN
THEIR LIVES IN THE NAME OF
EQUALITY I RESPECTFULLY URGE. I
VOTE ON SR THIRTY ONE. THANK
YOU SIR WINNER. BUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ON THE SERVER I- AS A
GAY MAN AND AS A SOMEONE WHO
HAD THE HONOR OF REPRESENTING
THE SUPERS ORIEL DISTRICT IN
SAN FRANCISCO THAT HARVEY MILK-
REPRESENTED IN THE LATE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES HARVEY MILK
IS DEEPLY IN MASS IN THE DNA OF
SAN FRANCISCO AND EVER LGBTQ
COMMUNITY- AND HE REALLY-
REPRESENTED A HUGE STEP FORWARD
FOR OUR COMMUNITY- WE SHOULD
ALWAYS REMEMBER THAT IT WASN'T
THAT LONG AGO- THAT THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY AND SAN FRANCISCO- IN
LOS ANGELES IN NEW YORK CITY.
AND CITIES THAT WE CONSIDER
TODAY TO BE SO PROGRESSIVE AND
SO PRO LGBTQ IT WASN'T THAT
LONG AGO- THAT OUR COMMUNITY
WAS DEEPLY MARGINALIZED EVEN IN
THESE LARGE PROGRESSIVE CITIES-
THAT THE POLICE WERE ROUTINELY
RATING OUR BARS AND OTHER
GATHERING SPACES AND
CRIMINALIZING- OUR COMMUNITY-
THAT WE WERE LARGELY SHUT OUT
OF THE POLITICAL PROCESS- THAT
WE WERE TOLD BY- WE SHOULDN'T
RUN FOR OFFICE RESEARCH TO
SUPPORT OTHER PEOPLE. ARE
RUNNING FOR OFFICE SAID IT
WASN'T NECESSARY FOR US TO HAVE
OUR OWN SEAT AT THE TABLE AND
THEN POLITICAL ORGANIZING
STARTED- AND ORGANIZATIONS WERE
FOUNDED ON DEMOCRATIC CLUBS
WERE FOUNDED- AND AT FIRST OUR
COMMUNITY WAS SUPPORTING OTHER
GREAT ALLIES- BUT THEN IT CAME
TIME TO ELECT OUR OWN AND
HARVEY WAS TRULY- IN THE
VANGUARD HE WAS NOT THE FIRST-
LGBTQ PERSON TO RUN. FOR
OFFICE- BUT HE ABSOLUTELY TOOK
IT TO THE NEXT LEVEL BY WINNING
ELECTION TO A SIGNIFICANT
OFFICE- IT TOOK HIM MULTIPLE
TRIES TO GET ELECTED BECAUSE
OTHER PEOPLE TOLD HIM. NO YOU
CAN IT'S NOT FOR YOU YOU YOU
CAN'T BE AT THE TAIL. AND HE
NOW GAVE UP HE KEPT GOING AND
THEY CAN OR HIM KEPT GOING AND
THE OLD. WON AND HE SAY
EVERYTHING I'M TO BE CLEAR THAT
BECAUSE OF HARVEY MILK. SPACE
EXISTS TODAY FOR PEOPLE LIKE ME
OR THE SENATOR FROM STOCKTON-
TO SERVE IN ELECTED OFFICE HE
WAS THAT IMPACTFUL HARVEY MILK
WAS A HERO- HE WATCHES OVER US
TODAY HE WAS BRUTALLY MURDERED.
AND THERE WAS NO ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR THAT MURDER WELCOME AGAIN
TO THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
AND HELP MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES LIVES ARE DEVALUED-
BUT HARVEY- WE LOVE YOU- AND
HAPPY BIRTHDAY. SENATOR LAWYER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PRESIDENT I RISE TO ONE MEMBER
OF THE LGBT CAUCUS WHO ACTUALLY
MATT HARVEY MILK. A. N. I SAW
HIM IN HIS THOSE EARLY RACES.
HE WAS INSPIRATIONAL AND WHEN
HE WAS KILLED AS SOMEBODY THAT
WAS FIRED TO POLITICAL LIFE. I
THOUGHT I HAD TO CHOOSE THE
RIGHT TO CHOOSE ABOUT BEING
CLEAR ABOUT WHO I WAS. FOUR TO
PURSUE THE CAREER I THOUGHT I
WOULD BE THE BEST. I ACTUALLY
WENT IN THE WILDERNESS FOR
AWHILE. IT TOOK A YEAR OFF AND
I DECIDED THAT IF I. LET PEOPLE
WITH ILL INTENT MAKE A DECISION
ABOUT MY FUTURE WAS THE WRONG
DECISION. AND I CAME BACK IN
FORTY YEARS AGO THIS NOVEMBER I
WAS ELECTED TO PUBLIC OFFICE.
AND AT THE TIME THERE WERE ONLY
TEN. OUT LGBT PEOPLE IN OFFICE
IN THE ENTIRE UNITED STATES
WHEN WE FORMED THE ELECTED
OFFICIALS ASSOCIATION IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE THERE WERE
FIFTEEN. AND YET IT WAS HIM
STANDING UP AND PROVIDING THE
BEACON FOR OTHER OF US TO DO
WHAT TO DO THE SAME FOR OTHER
PEOPLE. AND WHEN THE MOVIE MAIL
CAME OUT. I WOULDN'T GO TO SEE
IT FOR A NUMBER OF MONTHS
BECAUSE I THOUGHT WELL I KNEW
EVERYBODY AROUND THE MIND OF
THE PEOPLE THAT WERE PORTRAYED
IN THE MOVIE. AND I KNOW HOW
ENDS A I DIDN'T WORK FOR TO IT.
WHEN I FINALLY. I WAS STRUCK.
BY HOW FAR BEHIND THINGS WERE
WHEN HE WAS IN OFFICE THE FACT
THAT. THERE WERE POLICE RAIDS
ON ON PUBLIC VENUES AND THAT HE
WOULD GO TO THEM AND TRY TO
TROOPS TELL WHEN IT HAPPENED.
IT WAS A REAL TRIBUTE TO JUST
HOW FAR WE'VE COME AND IT WAS
BECAUSE OF HIM AND SO HAVING
THIS RESOLUTION AND HONORING
HIM EVERY YEAR IS HONORING THAT
ROLE. OF JUST MAKING A
DIFFERENCE IN PEOPLE'S LIVES
AND MAKING A DIFFERENCE FOR THE
FACT THAT. WHEN I WAS ELECTED
TO OFFICE. IS THERE NO MORE OUT
PEOPLE IN THE MONTEREY BAY HERE
YOU'RE DONE THERE WERE IN THE
ENTIRE UNITED STATES THEN IT'S
REALLY A TRIBUTE TO HIS. EFFORT
THAT'S WHY WE TO REMEMBER HIM
AND REMEMBERS WORK LAST FOUR
NINE VOTE ON SR. THIRTY ONE.
SENATOR SKINNER. YEAH OKAY NO
SHANNA.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS- BYSTANDERS THE VICE
CHAIR OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND
ALSO AS SOMEONE WHO DID MEET.
HARVEY MILK AND WHO REMEMBERS
VIVIDLY EXACTLY WHERE I WAS
WHEN I HEARD THAT HE AND MAYOR
MOSCONI HAD BEEN ASSASSINATED.
ON I WAS- HAD JUST DINNER- FEW
YEARS PRIOR TO MILK'S. ELECTION
GOTTEN VERY INVOLVED IN A
POLITICAL COALITION IN BERKELEY
THE SPACE RIGHT ACROSS FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND WE WAS LIKE THE
COALITION THAT HARVEY MILK WAS
ORGANIZING IN HE WAS A
BRILLIANT ORGANIZER. IT WAS
MADE UP OF MANY MANY GROUPS AND
THIS IS WHAT MANY PEOPLE DON'T
REALIZE ABOUT- SUPERVISOR MILK
IS THAT WHILE HE WAS CLEARLY
AND LOUDLY AND PROUDLY
ORGANIZING THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY
ANSWER TO SCOPE HE ALSO WAS
SPEAKING FOR MANY MARGINALIZED
GROUPS AND HE WORKED ON TENANTS
ISSUES ANY INVOLVED IN HIS
COALITION TENANTS- SENIORS- ON
THE DEED IT WAS A VERY DIVERSE
AND VERY- PEOPLE OF COLOR.
THOUGH THERE WAS A LITTLE THERE
WAS- SOME TENSIONS AROUND SOME
OF THE HOMOPHOBIA IN VARIOUS
COMMUNITIES BUT THE POINT I'M
TRYING TO MAKE IS THAT IN THE
EAST BAY ARE SIMILAR COALITION
HAD NOT YET INCLUDED IN OUR
PLATFORM ANY ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF
LGBTQ ISSUES BEYOND BECAUSE OF
MILK WE STARTED TO TALK ABOUT
THOSE INVEST THOSE AND THEN WE
REALIZED THAT MANY OF THE- OF
THE OTHER ACTIVISTS IN OUR-
ORGANIZATION WORK I'M GAY AND
JUST HAD NOT BEEN ASKED TO US.
AND SO WE THEN EMBRACE THAT IN
OUR PLATFORM AND ULTIMATELY- IN
FACT JUST WITHIN A FEW YEARS OF
MILK'S ASSASSINATION WHEN OUR
COALITION FINALLY GOT A
MAJORITY ON THE BERKELEY CITY
COUNCIL THE VERY FIRST VOTE WE
TOOK WAS ADOPTING A DOMESTIC
PARTNER BENEFITS TO GIVE- WELL
IT WAS NOT MARRIAGE IT WAS THE
CLOSEST WE COULD THINK OF AT
THAT POINT. ANYWAY HEARD WAS
JUST A VERY AMAZING. ORATORY AS
I SAID IN WE'RE- AND OF COURSE
A TRAILBLAZER AND SHE- FOR THE
RIGHTS OF A- Q. P. BUT ALSO
MANY OTHERS AND I SIT UP. STAND
IN SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAT. THANK
YOU- MISTER PRESIDENT SENATOR
SITE TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
R. THIRTY ONE AND IN SOLIDARITY
WITH THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY AS
CHAIR OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I
THANK MY GOOD FRIEND FROM
STOCKTON FOR BRING THIS FORWARD
AND ALSO WANT TO JUST REFLECT
ON ME IN THE WORDS OF MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM SAN FRANCISCO- WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT- THE EXPERIENCE
OF THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY IS-
THEY'RE TRYING TO. GET THEIR
POLITICAL VOICE NOT ONLY HEARD
BUT ALSO REPRESENTED AND THIS
IS A STORY THAT IS UNFORTUNATE
ALL TOO FAMILIAR- ALSO TO THE
API COMMUNITIES WELL WHERE
OFTENTIMES- WE